hallo hallo wie geht es dir heute aber
mir geht's gut
[Musik]
geht's
unser film der woche heißt wo ist hier
auch das ist so eine von den fragen die
nach nichts klingen aber es ist so eine
ähnliche frage wem gehört eigentlich
dieses blut oder können sie den schatten
auf dem röntgenbild erkennen denn bei
dieser frage geht es darum dass michelle
pfeiffer sich als ihre verstorbene
mutter verkleiden muss weil sie sonst
verhungern würde und aus der wohnung
fliegen also was zum gut fühlen oder
besten passend zur atmosphäre moment
einen film über soziale krise gut im
büro organisationen und freundlich auch
telefon
das sind besonders gut an dem film ist
wieder inszeniert ist das fängt bei der
schauspielführung an was allerdings
nicht sehr schwer gewesen sein kann weil
mich selbst haifa und kiefer sutherland
der ihren liebsten spielt in topform
sind es sind zwei richtig arme sei in
diesem fall der frau gesehen die so
aussieht und mutter sie gehen genau wie
sie ich hab so ausgesehen
man merkt dass sie sozusagen die
gelegenheit mit beiden händen ergreifen
mal was zu spielen wo es um was wir
kriegen das hin
ich darf diese wohnung nicht verlieren
möchte
er ist jung sie ist minuten musik den
scheck einlösen
außer der schauspielführung hast du aber
vor allen dingen le régina inszenierung
von goethes summe das ist ein uhr
spricht aus nigeria stammen der fotograf
und unter anderem videoclip regisseur
für leute wie isaac hayes oder wyclef
jean die ästhetisch tatsächlich auf
einem level ist dass man sich von dem
man auch im film über gar nichts
anschauen würde das ist aber kein oder
gar nichts der geht mit licht um wie
irgendwie zwischen horrorfilme und
italienischen neorealismus der geht mit
geräuschen um in der weise wie man das
sonst vielleicht david lynch hat also
die tonspur ist ein eigenes wahnsinns
hörspiel der geht mit
gegenüberstellungen um von was ist ein
innenraum wo du das gefühl hast die
tapeten sie werden sie rücken immer
näher an dich ran und zerquetschen dich
und dann wechselt er in außenräumen bzw
in öffentliche räume in der bank zum
beispiel wurde das gefühl hast du wirst
auseinander gezogen wenn du sie betritt
so quälend leer ist die wenn du an die
reihe kommt und an den schalter muss und
jemand anders spielen muss es ist kurz
wir haben was mit dir passiert wenn sie
mich erwischen
das weiß ich glaubst du das weiß ich
nicht ich stehe hier sollten die damen
verdammte scheiße durch des genannten
also der punkt ist es ist im grunde wie
diese kaffer geschichte von der maus der
die katze hinterher setzt und dann heißt
es ja wenn die ecke getrieben ist was
machst du denn du kannst die
laufrichtung ende einer frist ich halt
die katze der spielraum für
geschäftsleiter wird eigentlich immer
enger herbst dass sich jeder einfach
aufgegeben hat und wenn du dann am boden
gott sei dank hat es meine mutter sehen
wir die nacht an der künstlerischen und
inhaltlichen qualität gibt es eigentlich
nichts zu deuten das große rätsel wäre
wenn man was deuten will warum der erst
zwei jahre später kommt als zwei jahre
nachdem er eigentlich hätte kommen
können der film ist zwei jahre alt
ich nehme an die erklärung ist ein
bisschen die dass man einerseits sagen
kann er hat beides er hat was ein
arthouse film hat und er hat was ein
hollywood film hat er hat aber auch
beides nicht denn er hat zwei dinge die
jeweils das eine publikum nicht möchte
nämlich einen zu schweren stoff
beziehungsweise für die die schweren
stoffe mögen zu berühmte leute vor der
linse es gibt ja so eine snobismus der
den großen stars ausweicht und dieses
zwischen den stühlen hängen hat
wahrscheinlich dazu geführt dass man
erst jetzt jubeln kann in deutschland
aber umso mehr sollte man jugend und vor
allem sollen
da bin ich mir nicht mehr so sicher
[Musik]